[Music]
[Applause]
he's Chris Sims pro football talk live
co-host and he works on football night
America former NFL quarterback and uh
before I get to Thursday Night Football
we just uh we had somebody call in say
more electrifying quarterback Michael
Vic Lamar
Jackson not better electrifying right
gosh I mean listen I think the world of
Lamar Jackson don't get me wrong but but
I mean I saw Michael Vic firsthand and
you know he was the first of his kind as
far as anything like what we're seeing
today uh it was just rare first off I
mean let's set it up I mean going back
to the old Atlanta Dome back in the day
with the DJ in the third rle and Michael
Vic was playing man that place was
hopping and then Nike commercial that's
a roller coaster ride that should just
tell you how electric it was and then
watching him on the football field right
he had a rocket left arm and the
quarterback was the fastest guy on the
field you know I never found myself more
on the sidelines on like third and 18
going I hope we can stop him from not
getting the first down right he he
turned the corner and run you'd be like
oh no he's going to get 20 uh so I'll go
with Michael Vic there he was Unreal to
watch him person all right Thursday
Night Football we got the bills and the
Buccaneers and it's a no- win situation
for Buffalo even if you win you're
supposed to then we're going to look at
it with style points how did they win
how did Josh Allen do Stefon Diggs happy
like there's a lot going on in Buffalo I
don't know exactly what it is and also
what do you see when you see Josh Allen
right well I I mean one injuries on the
defense right that's a big issue for
them I think that's why you've seen them
kind of fall apart a little there Matt
Milano you can't you know disregard that
injury definitely one of the best
linebackers in football probably the
best player on their defense travius
white other injuries in the secondary Ed
Oliver wasn't hurt right dayquan Jones
their big D tackle who's really good
he's done for the year so they got
issues there offensively Dan you've
heard me say this before right they're
just not enough there and there's not
enough there as far as premium Talent
compared to the other teams let alone
the scheme itself is there's nothing
Elite that they do what do you defend
when you defend the Buffalo Bills right
now there to me the last three games
have shown it and last three games which
I you know because my podcast listeners
want me to explain what's going on with
the bills three teams in a row basically
said we're not going to let Josh Allen
throw 60 yard lasers and we're not going
to let him run around and make magic
plays if we stop those two things their
offense is pretty average and I think
that's what you're seeing here more than
anything they have no element of their
offense that makes the defense go oh
wait we have to stop this or this and
that and they so they're never
compromised it's all about just stopping
17 and he's going to throw to Diggs and
after that everybody else can live with
the the
repercussions yeah I I just it feels
like Stefon Diggs is one moment away
from you know blowing up here and I I
don't know it's it it feels frustrated
window of opportunity is closing rapidly
because it felt like the media was
pushing like Josh Allen MVP Bills going
to the Super Bowl and now they've cooled
considerably and I just wonder where
they stand in the AFC right now of yeah
you know Super Bowl contenders no yeah I
I think they're down the list
considerably I I don't I before the year
started Dan and I'm not trying to you
know I'm wrong a lot you know I'm right
a lot too I I did not pick them to go to
the playoffs I did not look at them as a
playoff team you know I looked at it and
went wait it's the same team as last
year they got a tight end in the first
round and they got a new guard to play
with to me that wasn't enough to go oh
they're ready to compete with Kansas
City and Baltimore and Miami and those
type of football teams on a weekly basis
no you know it's too much and and I
talked to people around the league about
the bills all the time and and I said
this today on PFT to Mike flua you know
I've been and and I said this and and
and and and I'll even say it again Devin
mccordi myself we've talked to people up
in buffal who have basically said like
they don't feel they can win the game
unless Josh Allen takes over there's
that feeling there there's just not
enough there he's one of the greatest
talents in the sport he is phenomenal
but every week is about him playing with
his hair on fire and him making magic
happen and throwing to Stefon Diggs and
after that you just go well who's going
to be something else this week on the
offense and I think the Bucks will keep
that game uncomfortably close for them
tonight if they don't make the playoffs
then
what that's a big question I would think
that I you know I'm not in favor of a
regime change I'm not I'm definitely not
I'm a Believer in mcder and what he's
done up there and like you kind of said
they've been in the Super Bowl window
for like four or five years here right
you know they've built a damn good team
I think biggest thing I think one if
they don't get to the playoffs you're
going to hear talk about Ken dorsy right
whether that's right or not that's
what's going to happen and then the
other thing is I think you're going to
hear a lot of like hey they got to get
some other star players on their
football team especially the offensive
side of the ball there's got to be more
Sizzle to that football team you know
you look at the other top teams in the
AFC and we can go through Jacksonville
Baltimore Miami Kansas City right uh
gosh you even get into like Cleveland
and I'd go their skill guys are all
better than Buffalo and I that's
concerning a a little bit Brock p is in
the concussion
protocol now you have Sam
darnold he's still 26 he's been 26 for
three years it feels like so he's going
to be able to come in and play Kyle
shanan doesn't matter who's the
quarterback they're going to probably
put up good numbers can Sam darnold
somehow play him into a starting Ro
elsewhere a job
offer I I think he needs more than one
game right I think one game will make
people feel good and you know that can
probably like lock down a high-end
backup job next year no matter what to
where he gets paid good backup money but
Garo got this Matt Flynn got this uh
right I mean there have been guys who
have gotten contract off of two or three
good good games you're right yeah you're
right you know I think there's a little
bit more Scar Tissue with Sam darnold
around the NFL from what we've seen with
other teams and there to where you know
I'm not sure everyone's just going to
buy into Sam darnold Shanahan believes
in the guy he's got talent as you said
it I mean Shanahan makes a lot of
quarterbacks look really really damn
good right but I do think to be a
starter I think he'd probably need yeah
you know two three four four games to
kind of to prove that to a team to go
okay wait we're ready to pay him
significant money to be a starter for
our football team we're talking to Chris
Sims pro football talk live co-host
contributes to football night in America
I'm wondering about the boredom of the
media sometimes because when you we keep
waiting for a team to supplant the
Kansas City Chiefs right right and
they've got the shest thing in football
they got momes to Kelce right right
nobody has that it's stock into
Malone every year you know it's coming
you can't stop it right so it feels like
we get bored and we need that new story
and we keep trying to go outside the
lines and go you know the Dolphins I'm
just saying that they could be hey the
Bengals don't count Browns don't count
them out you know the Ravens
dark Kansas City is still the team to
beat in the AFC correct I correct
correct now are they perfect no they're
another team that I kind of look at
right now and go they could use a little
more Firepower on the offensive side of
the ball in my opinion is what's
different about them this year though is
they can run the ball and they have
their D is legit I mean it's legit
scoring points against that team moving
the ball it's not easy so that's where
they're a little different and then like
you're saying I mean 15 is already in
the upper room of the Hall of Fame he's
like a Hall of Famer of Hall of Famers
here already we're talking about already
one of the alltime greats of the sport
and you're right so you know even
without the lack of Fire play Power the
way he plays the creativity of Andy Reid
and Matt ngi a little bit that makes up
for the lack of Firepower in that
department but yes they're the Kings
until the throne there now Baltimore is
the real deal I like B I like and
Jacksonville I think is a team too to
continue to watch here that has complete
Talent across the roster they're young
they're still learning how to win a
little bit but when they play those two
teams the Ravens and Jags play their
best I look at them on film Dan and go
whoa they're up there with the big boys
now they just got to do it more
consistently but uh I think those are
two teams to me that have the talent and
uh across the board to to maybe pull an
upset off against the the Chiefs in the
playoffs and the chief's defense is
ranked higher than the chief's offense
for the first time since Mahomes has
been there that's the scary part to me
exactly that that's where I go okay now
you have my attention uhhuh I it's it's
the Chiefs we all know they're throwing
and their points and it's sexy and it's
fun to watch the one thing they don't
get credit for their o line can pass
protect and their defense every year
even when they weren't as statistically
good as they are this year when they
need to get physical in an AFC title
game and stop Derrick Henry in the Run
game they do it oh we got to stop
Shanahan in the 49ers in the Run game of
the Super Bowl they do it they don't get
the respect for the physicality they
have oh we got to stop the and the best
offensive line we've seen in football in
the last 15 years oh we'll do it so
there's a little nice blend of
creativity and Showmanship and toughness
with that Chiefs team that I absolutely
love great to talk to you as always
thanks Dan thank always great talking to
you tell the guys I said what's up your
hair looks good as always top button is
buttoned I mean when you go home yes is
the top button buttoned when you walk in
to say hello to your wife and kids if
there's a button up top it's it's
buttoned up man all the time I don't
always when you go to bed and you have
your pajamas are they buttoned all the
way to the to um you know lack for I'm a
naked sleeper Dan sorry that's probably
too much information but that's how I
sleep all
right hold on nothing nothing I I can't
stand it I can't stand anything on me
anywhere so yes uh I need a Second
Source on this all right well my wife
loves you right so if you want to bring
her on sometime and she can tell you all
about it all righty all right thank you
Chris all right guys see you Chris Sims
pro football talk live co-host now try
to get that image out of your
head maybe you don't want to yeah maybe
you don't want to